gayroom Greggy Cody and I be the third
for that probably not probably not it
just shows tie roots it just shows to
every floor with her ah look at that
it's me I don't know how to eat stuff
gotta work on your agency would I be
doing if I see here's the thing about me
like I said obsessed with Ghostbusters
but the first obsession was Superman
okay and so you would have been sick
with that can you unplug me what I think
I would've been is what cuz i was
talking about this is that i think I'd
base most of my life choices on just
attaching myself to the Superman Laura
in the beginning right knew I wanted to
wear nerd glasses from the start really
knew I wanted to be a journalist I have
a degree in journalism that's eventually
how I knew I'd get into video games
writing about games and stuff now you
might say Greg you're overweight
Superman isn't overweight but I would
not say that to you damn uh the thing
about our Superman doesn't have to work
out right Superman well first off he's
working out when he's pushing stuff
around but you remember of course in the
can and adventure Lewis and Clark's the
New Adventures of Superman decaying
looked like Dean Cain and he just had
Cubs fooled with cookies oh yeah so I
think I base my decisions on that what
and there you go so I think it all works
out so if I what it's just realities
fault that you're not you know you
didn't get to right it's always somebody
else's fault that I look like this
ripley's believe it or not right Oh
Ripley blame it on someone else deep
deep deep cut on details IMDB page right
there but I probably be if I wasn't
hanging out talking about games I
probably still be a journalist somewhere
yeah i bet i would have kept going that
way well what else what else do you
think in terms of like maybe media would
have been sports woulda been card events
you think like it you know before I
books obviously yeah that would have
been a good one I think probably if for
some reason video games never come
around I loved wizard magazine so
reading that and seeing how much fun
those guys were having probably been a
good one I thought about that too you
know IGN com does a bunch of different
things right and the one I've always
loved the comics side of our site where
I'm just like man I would I in a
different world I would have loved to
have written for that and done comic
based content for the shoe the channel
notice the future yeah this video games
are gonna make it I know totally look at
this to just remaking old ones though
we're looking at Wolfenstein new order
here which is a great collaboration
between a fantastic English
rock band and your favorite nazi killing
and simulator chris waters even like a
bunch of this yes at give me the
elevator pitch a code is this video game
this could have gone either way it's
really good yeah it's really fun it's
just like a great fun shooter business
you get to knife and not see the ball I
guess that's already get another shot
he's not super alert oh crap oh now
who's super bad situation all right Oh
Stella got out the window anyway oh no
there's a dog with a Nazi robot dogs
they have right this one's this one's
only send my robotic Oh what what are
you doing on the ground the dog knocked
him over oh gods well that guy just go
that was weird and he went over here
crap video games are having a lot of
guns and what are you playing the Sun
this is on the Xbox one it looks really
pretty it is a very good looking game
I'm playing it on a difficulty level
that is four out of five ok I've culties
on the difficulties goober the hardest
difficulty yes so this is not uber I
need to it goes ok if you've any
questions at all i babble to sign the
order to HK more comments or at gamespot
on the twitters from what I played I'm a
big fan of Wolfenstein so far yeah so
how do you how would you place it on you
know like your compared to like a modern
shooter right I mean certainly more in
the call of duty vain in terms of your
mobility it's not it's not a titanfall
it's not a halo it's in terms of the
gunplay you know I think crank I've been
playing it on uber difficulty for the
most part and cranking up the difficulty
does make it significantly harder you'll
see like I got overwhelmed there I had
to stay behind cover just to stay alive
and then dudes were all over me so it
kind of it it wants to hark back to that
old school feel right I mean for me I'm
playing on normal cuz I'm a worse and I
do love the fact that when I started to
move the difficulty around it
immediately started insulting me like
I'm really it shows like him as a baby
or them him and blood shows the face
yeah but like for me it's a happy Video
Game equivalent to like you know the
blockbuster movie right it's a popcorn
movie
it's over the top you're in a coma for
14 years and you snap out of it and
start stabbing Nazis and breaking their
necks and it's like yeah he has these
ridiculous lines are ridiculous enemies
you can throw a knife and if you
actually hit somebody it's a one hit
kill I don't know what it was my
terrible knife throw as you go I give
these amazing kills like that I guess
it's a fun like stupid in quote game I'm
getting a kind of a bullet storm we live
off in that respect that it's kind of
like it's not taking so serious yeah
that's the big part of it right so the
idea is like these guys oh god yeah I've
got this sick laser gun that's kind of
upgraded it actually has this like auto
targeting thing now but it takes a lot
of energy so you got to go to these
energy chart stations to recharge it oh
it's apt life I got it that broadcasting
alarm thing is a problem for me because
it's just going to call reinforcements
the whole time all he does that I do
that is there a set number of dudes or
is it just gonna monster closet these
guys into because usually I take care to
kill the commanders before they can
broadcast the alarm have you family add
the story stuff so far chris uh so yeah
that's it's been an interesting part of
it considering story is not something
people really consider you know a heavy
part of the nostalgia trip Wolfenstein
it's a lot better mean obviously it's it
there is a story there is a bj
blaskowitz is a character like you know
he is sure he's the like beat the crap
out of Nazis character but uh not being
my rockness here but he's also like he
kind of recognizes the horrors of war
and has this like ragtag group of
resistance fighters that are also
characters in their own right that you
get to get to come to know and uh die
horribly and talking about video games
while talking already are always
difficult I like it because it also does
this thing that where it has um you know
you'll go from sort of stealth Inc
sections which I've just basically
finished at this point I'm in the middle
i'm like halfway this is at this point
is about to third halfway or two-thirds
through the game how long is even
playing for ah does it feel long enough
i don't know if that does feel
substantial because of course there's no
multiplayer component on this correct it
feels substantially long and it also has
these moments that where you are like in
the hideout with the resistance fighters
like talking to them about stuff like
exploring the the area to like find them
some thing they need to help out all
right let's
do something different here I'm gonna go
with the silenced and instead of the
knife throw because the knife throat I
have been I believe me they just hate
that crate YouTube can keep trying to
create kill oh hello friend hello he was
looking right at you he's gonna regret
that I think I'm gonna regret that yeah
they know because they are yelling your
pistol made no noise but his head
exploding made a load of noise that is
not a gun not in gun mode he has a
swastika on his like collar yacht like
his name is swastika they wanted to make
sure you didn't you know if you run into
a cybernetic dog on the street you need
to know at a glance if it's a Nazi or a
Jew and so they like nazis are like
we're gonna pretty quickly put it out
you're gonna make sure it's one of those
it's one of our dogs yeah that's the
only way anyone you would Jewish doggy
oh you're one of our robot evil dog
alright so I'm with me you've also got
regeneration pretty not really like he's
always down to uh I was down to three
health their way up to 20 oh I'm at 13
I'm gonna go back up to 20 you
regenerate two increments of 20 so it's
okay neat little straddling of the
regenerating health paradox that as you
know I've never really been solved yeah
for better or worse has you know taking
a huge role in modern shooters the huge
sort of contentious role I'm this brings
back the old school overcharged mode too
or if you're at 100 you get an x-ray you
go into gold you can have like 140 in a
slowly starts counting down okay you did
on this as well yeah awesome all right I
got some questions coming in here and
near burn 82 just some technical ones
first I heard the weapon switching isn't
that great is that true this is the
weapon switching it's on the wheel you
kind of got a point to it i would say
it's you know it's a little it takes a
little bit of getting used to to be able
to do it in the heat of combat you saw
me earlier like switching to
accidentally to my laser going but it's
actually in cutting mode and not in fri
and not cite code could you just hot
switch between two to Ike and so I can
boom hot okay so your previous hello
4head i heard some oh my god i got a
machine gun Eminem strange on twitch
asked those stealth have good AI for
enemies this is a constant worry on
first-person games ah it's not like you
know it's not even something as
complicated as dishonored where they're
gonna be in different sort of
states of investigating you and you have
to like double evade them when they're a
little bit alerted they're either
alerted or they're not so if you're
creeping into a base in one of those
levels and you trip a switch that's it
game over you're going to be shooting
those dudes like I only open for the
rest of the section absolutely and yeah
you're gonna meeting a friend here in a
second so I'm gonna try to find some
more health which you can find in some
of these crates these anything that has
metal that looks like this can be cut
open oh that's great and so like
hopefully there's some armor ceiling
wait a second has the new wolfenstein
just actually reinvented crates yes the
game the get a separate invented rates
gave us a new mechanic in relation to
cry you can cut them open my god yeah
there starts you off on ones you can
just break yeah but then it does it goes
next gen and gives you the crate yell
like there's one that you can just knife
there you all right it's a they don't
want they don't wanna lose people they
were a young and old to be able to get
passionate creatures that I don't like
these new crates in this video game it's
not one like when I was a kid all right
and you still eat plates of chicken for
can you tell you found any place of
chicken but you know how they have these
dogs which you can just take the armor
off of them and put them on you put it
on yourself this is big you can eat
bowls of not dog food great really yeah
Wow like they went you can come across
dog food and you just like Tom it down
plus for health at cell processing on
twigs can you step through the entire
game no you cannot for example that guy
at can you steal Nazi gold I can
Wolfenstein 3d so they did yeah there's
lots of nuts over the older so I that
was easy that was easy because I a Nazi
suck you don't actually get the this
attachment for this weapon until a
couple levels from now ok so I'm making
it look a little easier than it actually
is but like I can grab this dude's metal
and just like I just like love this
image of like yeah just like got a paper
to is Jason yeah he's just always rain
the metal scoring a stack of eight Nazi
hats like but moving perfectly stuffy
yeah no problem ahem ahem how much of
this game if you spent rubbing up
against walls and smashing a space bar 0
ah it's a real one they're all like
Hitler I haven't there's like a blurry
one that kind of looks like him but they
don't really talk about
ler a lot like death's-head is the chief
antagonist and you meet him early go did
you meet him you're taught playtime how
was that music awesome squash right I
mean like it's so creepy the game does
stuff that it has no business doing its
it has no business being as much fun as
it is both in cutscene form and gameplay
form because it's just like you're
running around blowing stuff up fighting
these crazy-ass enemies like we're you
were talking about Nazis just putting
Nazi symbols on everything it's a god I
hate you guys more than ever yep that's
what they do but yeah man it's and it's
got kid like I've said this before when
we sort of had it on stream and stuff
the villains have character and that
just makes it so much more satisfying
they make you hate them yeah I mean on
top of all the horrible things Nazis do
yeah but on top of that it even more
automated reason people right yeah yeah
it much more yeah make them great aunt
Agnes and now this is going to good you
know even if I'd still threw that up how
what I had to fight the monster right
here now there's like there's a ton more
Nazis I die my way all right I'm gonna
ask you both a question and ask Greg
first sure add this is a game that high
is a first-person game associated pc and
there's this long conversation about
multiplayer in relation to first-person
games generally so there is a kind of an
omission in relation to this linear
first-person shooter game that does not
have multiplayer do you think that that
is a problem that just made up of forum
posts and message boards and doesn't
should not really exist that it's like
unreasonable to expect every game type
multiplayer or do you feel like this is
leslie package because it doesn't matter
i think it's a hundred percent made up
thing i mean it's it's back to just I
but you know line items on the back of a
box right I understand it's video games
cost a lot of money and everybody
understands this they want you to feel
like you're getting a lot free money but
how many games have you played where you
never touch the multiplayer mode tomb
raider or you touch the multiplayer mode
it's just garbage you know i mean i'd
rather see one hundred twenty percent
these guys be like it because it works
we're making this fun game that's a
popcorn movie that's totally over the
top and goofy let's focus on that and
make that the best it can be and not
worry about shoehorning in it or going
you know giving some other developer you
make the multiple for us and well try to
piece them together and you'll get coins
that carry over now like don't even
worry about it you're not I mean like I
think developers should be allowed to
have a vision
create it and not have to be bogged down
with what crap now we need this oh i
think there's a salient example it also
uses the attack five engine which is
rage I mean that game was a real bulky
single-player shooter and then the
multiplayer mode was like a demolition
derby yea RS and it was totally
uninteresting it was totally tagged on
like not not an interesting way to spend
time and yeah it had it tech HX the box
for multiplayer but what did anyone like
really enjoy that a bunch I don't think
so I mean I certainly didn't and oh god
just die just yet so these are ricochet
shells sure are I can tell me that
because there's his gun did you friendly
fire turn can you hurt yourself ah no
you cannot hurt yourself come on BJ
blaskowitz hurt himself no way ever ah
yeah so I think that you know there's
the great thing about the gay ministry
that we continue to see your dr despite
the you know avalanche of sequels and
games that are seen the same as other
games is the is new niches being filled
new niches being created and i think
that the single-player
first-person-shooter okay that's some
hot lap all there was somebody up there
followed me up there alright so there's
another way to finish this which i'll
just do now well i can expedite this as
long as you want I think there's the
niche of single-player only first-person
shooter got lost in the avalanche of
like you know we're now councils can go
online now Council online multiplayer is
the hot thing like it's got to have
multiplayer especially if you're
shooting something that's a naturally
competitive endeavor you want to shoot
someone else in the face it's human
nature in a virtual setting absolutely
but you know it's I think that it's
great to have games like this and I
think that this game you know it's sort
of it shows in the care that this
campaign has in the stuff you like you
were mentioning earlier there it feels
like it has no business doing it but of
course it should do this stuff of course
a shooter campaign should like have
character should have you know should be
challenging should have a lot of
environments and weapons and all the
stuff I'm going to go back and think
about some other like the best
first-person shooters I've played over
on console specifically over the past
generation like it's games like like
portal and bioshock infinite which
didn't get want to bear until the dlc i
believe
and for Bioshock 1 or flash out why I
said about a shock to it oh yes I am and
then I'm Bethesda side I guess they're
there are no strangers to make
incredible single-player campaigns sure
single-player games with the other
schools and fallout series so like we
had Pete Hines on the show at pax live
lobbies and like he put forward that
idea that like it is increasingly
difficult to try and create games that
take both areas yeah always sacrifice
something and doing one we need during
the other and so yeah I kind of
interested to you know especially when
you're trying to make something this
caliber that kind of budget that's
involved in and just making a single
player campaign campaign is expensive
man licensing for swastikas is like
insane and you know who talked about
that a lot was Vincent pehle and respawn
those guys talking about making
titanfall multiplayer only shooter yeah
like valid points about the the
investment versus the sort of player
time that you get out of a single player
campaign in a multiplayer-focused
shooter I feel like this is the week
where it's getting super exciting in
terms of new releases for these consoles
we're getting this we've transistor
watch dogs is our next week I believe
yeah and then we're straight into III
and it's going to be a whole bunch of
mess about what's coming up to the next
have you felt like it's kind of simmered
down a bit over since yeah yeah I mean
when I mean when we brought the boxes
home right it was the excitement of
having it and then the I guess I'll play
Lego Marvel again like get out of me
like there wasn't those driving forces
and that's why you had titanfall and
second son out is like those in the
lighthouses were going towards those the
ones we can't wait to then we got those
got lost nose and then on the other side
it's been that what next and I'm sure I
mean like for Wolfenstein I'm sure
that's going to work to its favor right
the fact that you know it's a game that
everybody loves and it's no business
being this good that's kind of a
backhanded insult right but it's like
people are here now like okay great i'm
totally in for something different
something cool and something goofy to go
play with what do you think about the
perception that so as a consumer buying
a Mudder you explain all t player then
you kind of think like oh well if it's
got multiplayer then if well if it's
gonna have a lot of multi player and i'm
not really going to want to play the
multi player then it is is it a bad
value proposition for me to buy the game
right like mi is it not
going to be worth it because because i'm
not a huge multiplayer fan i'm not going
to be taking advantage of this
significant portion of the game I
definitely that's something on people's
mind you know I mean I think that's why
they're promoting it the way they're
promoting it they're promoting it on the
strength of the brand Wolfenstein the
name Wolfenstein that song means a lot
to a lot of gamers you know I mean
especially now with everybody having
these consoles or you know the fervor
around them I think the fact that
they're coming out and doing that and
making all about BJ blaskowitz of the
campaigns and map showing with gigantic
chainsaw oh oh oh no oh yeah I think
that sums up the experience of playing
wolfenstein about uber soldier that I
uber soldier Chris waters thank you very
much for playing some of this mess with
us my pleasure i was glad I was able to
succeed to some degree thanks mate I'm
fall earlier as well yeah we are hard as
we are giving this game away